ein duell der entgleisungen die erste
fernsehdebatte zwischen us-präsident
trump und herausforderer beiden wird
über weite strecken zur chaotischen
schlammschlacht nachspiel in diesen
skandal der ehemalige vorstandschef von
audi sitzt jetzt auf der anklagebank
ihm droht eine lange haftstrafe und
neuer trainer bei schalke 04 manuel baum
soll den verein aus der krise führen
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und in allen und danke
dass sie bei uns sind das schon mal
vorweg dieser nachrichten tag im
überblick und katja stresow hat nachher
den sport guten namen davon mir würdelos
das ist noch eine der vorsichtigen
beschreibungen von amerikanischen
kommentatoren für das was eigentlich ein
höhepunkt des wahlkampfes ums weiße haus
werden sollte
das erste direkte fernsehduell zwischen
präsident donald trump und seinem
herausforderer joe biden
es wurden eineinhalb stunden chaos die
in die geschichte eingehen werden
über weite strecken war es gar kein
gespräch mehr den man einigermaßen hätte
folgen können
90 minuten giftige debatte
zusammengefasst jetzt in zweieinhalb
minuten von britta jäger einen
handschlag gibt es nicht zu beginn wegen
coro den beiden kontrahenten dürfte es
wohl ganz recht gewesen sein
trump gegen beiden zum ersten mal
treffen sie in einer tv-debatte
aufeinander
es werden 90 minuten aggressives
wortgefecht fakt ist dass das was er
sagt gelogen ist ich brauche das hier
nicht zu benennen jeder weiß dass er ein
lügner ist
du hättest den job nie machen können so
wie wir ihn gemacht haben du hast es
nicht im blut nichts an die ist schlau
so in 47 jahren hast du nichts hänge
krieg trump versucht beiden mit attacken
buchstäblich zu überrollen fällt ihm
ständig ins wort und bricht damit die
debatten regeln moderator chris wallace
hat schwierigkeiten die diskussion zu
lenken beiden pariert tram solle die
klappe halten und man komme gar nicht zu
wort bei diesem clown wahlkampfteam hat
zugestimmt dass jede seite zwei minuten
ununterbrochen reden darf ihre seite war
einverstanden
eine chaos debatte bei der inhalt
beinahe nebensächlich erscheint eines
der großen themen die korona krise und
deren wirtschaftliche folgen
beiden wirft von planlosigkeit vor er
wusste schon im februar wie schlimm die
krise ist dass es eine tödliche
krankheit ist sie sollten aus ihrem
bunker rauskommen ihren golfplatz
verlassen und lieber mal im weißen haus
mit demokraten und republikanern einen
plan entwickeln
wir sind nur wenige wochen von einem
impfstoff entfernt wir behandeln die
erkrankten es sterben weniger menschen
wir haben einen tollen job gemacht
beiden beschimpft trump als
schoßhündchen des russischen präsidenten
und als rassisten trump lobt er sei für
die stärkste wirtschaft der us
geschichte verantwortlich und er weigert
sich weiße rassisten zu verurteilen als
beiden die rechtsextreme gruppe cottbus
erwähnt kommt von tram face haltet euch
zurück und haltet euch bereit ich sage 1
jemand muss etwas gegen antifa und die
linken tun
trump werde seine anhänger dazu aufrufen
die auszählung der stimmen genau zu
beobachten wieder wettert er gegen die
briefwahl spricht von wahlbetrug der
präsident versuche bürger von der
stimmabgabe abzuhalten sagt beiden und
wendet sich direkt ans volk
sie werden den ausgang dieser wahl
bestimmen wählen wählen wählen
inhaltlich neues lieferten die gegner
nicht bei dem schlagabtausch den wählern
dürfte vor allem das aggressive chaos im
gedächtnis bleiben
das kann man so sagen und elmar theveßen
hat die ganze nacht das für uns
begleitet in cleveland ohio immer wer
kann der nach dieser denkwürdigen
schlammschlacht jetzt mehr punkte machen
für den wahlkampf also es gibt ein paar
erste blitzumfragen die sagen dass joe
biden die nase vorn hat das hat
vielleicht aber eher damit zu tun dass
er im auge des betrachters sich etwas
anständiges verhalten hat als donald
trump er hat auch ein paar inhaltliche
punkte machen können aber im
wesentlichen da sind sich viele menschen
hier einig war dass eine schande was da
zu sehen war ein würdeloses schauspiel
ein kollege des amerikanischen
fernsehens sagte im kampf um das höchste
amt war das unterste schublade und nach
den umfragen sagen etwa 70 prozent der
amerikaner
ja das war so und das deutet darauf hin
dass donald trump jedenfalls nicht
aufholen kann
in der jagd hinter joe biden der etwa
zehn prozentpunkte vor ihm weg aber das
ansehen der präsidentschafts debatte an
sich hat das ganze bestimmt sehr
geschadet
und dann müssen wir über die letzten
minuten dieser debatte reden als große
sorge aufkam was sind ablauf eines
möglichen machtwechsels angeht wie hoch
ist denn die gefahr dass diese wahl im
chaos auf der straße und möglicherweise
auch in gewalt endet ja ist da vieles so
aus als wollte trump ein stück weit das
vertrauen in die demokratischen prozesse
in diesem land und auch die lust am
demokratischen prozess stark beschädigen
gleichzeitig wurde er ja auch gefragt
genau wie joe biden ob er denn eine
niederlage anerkennen würde joe biden
hat ganz klar gesagt wenn die zahlen das
hergeben werde er die niederlage
anerkennen donald trump hat sich
geweigert und dann sagt er auch noch
dass sich die rechtsextremisten bereit
halten sollen
das sind alles signale die er aussendet
dass er das wahlergebnis vielleicht
nicht anerkennen würde
und wir müssen uns deshalb sicherlich
nicht nur auf einen sehr hässlichen
weiteren wahlkampf einstellen sondern
möglicherweise auch auf eine situation
wie wir sie in amerika seit vielen
jahrzehnten nach wahl nicht mehr erlebt
haben immer dankeschön
diese spezielle debatte in den usa in
allen facetten gibt es bei uns online in
der zdf- heute- app finden sie einen
faktencheck weitere reaktionen und wenn
sie wollen noch einmal das duell in
voller länge
unser nächstes thema heute abend die
zahl der gemeldeten neuen corona
infektionen bleibt heute mehr oder
weniger unverändert in deutschland in
der politik steigt aber die sorge vor
herbst und winter und gleichzeitig
steigt die sorge von neuen drastischen
einschränkungen
seit gestern sind neue krone regeln für
deutschland beschlossen bußgeld etwa für
die die sich mit falschem namen in den
corona listen im restaurant eintragen
christoph distel altstadt düsseldorf
auch hier gilt ist trinkt aber trag dich
in die liste ein wer schummelt zahlt
mindestens 50 euro dieses mindestens von
bund und ländern liegt nrw ab morgen so
aus 250 euro bußgeld pro verstoß und die
wirte sollen die namen kontrollieren
auch im
leicht gemacht vielleicht bei donald
duck aber bei hans müller die uhrzeiten
kontrollieren wir aber personalausweis
kontrollieren wir natürlich nicht weil
wir es auch nicht dürfen
theorie und praxis auch bei den party
obergrenzen ein problem in hotspots
maximal zehn personen heißt es wer zählt
danach dabei drängen die
infektionszahlen weiter zum handeln im
schnitt haben sich 1870 menschen
angesteckt genauso viel wie gestern mit
riesigen regionalen unterschieden stadt
und landkreis rostock etwa melden
zusammen einen fall pro 100000 einwohner
in der letzten woche berlin dagegen
kommt auf 31 und berlin-mitte sogar auf
48 weshalb die hauptstadt noch über die
bund länder vorgaben hinaus geht in
büros gilt ab samstag masken pflicht
wenn auch nur im gang und im aufzug
bringt doch nichts schimpft die
wirtschaft ich kenne keine probleme aus
unternehmen wo es tatsächlich im umgang
der mitarbeitenden untereinander zu hohe
ansteckungsgefahr ist das ist ja auch
klar
die unternehmen haben natürlich ein
ureigenes interesse daran ihre
beschäftigten zu schützen und zu rücken
partys und geselligkeiten noch mehr in
den fokus
ob corona zum winter hin in schach
gehalten werden kann wird sich wohl vor
allem am tresen entscheiden
die korona krise und ein ungewöhnlich
emotionalen appell der bundeskanzlerin
prägen die generaldebatte heute im
deutschen bundestag wegen der steigenden
infektionszahlen bad angela merkel die
deutschen vorsichtiger zu sein und nicht
alles aufs spiel zu setzen
heftige kritik an den corona maßnahmen
der regierung kam von der opposition
weniger berichtet angela merkel ist
eigentlich schon am schluss ihrer rede
angekommen hat 30 jahre deutsche einheit
haushalt und andere themen gestreift da
sagt sie routine gehe nicht und kommt
noch mal auf corona zurück ich bin
sicher das leben wie wir es kannten
wirkt zurückkehren
die familien werden wieder feiern die
clubs und theater und fußball stadien
wieder voll sein und was für eine
freude wird das sein aber jetzt müssen
wir zeigen dass wir weiter geduldig und
vernünftig handeln und so leben retten
können jetzt müssen wir verstehen dass
es weiter auf jeden und jede einzelne
ankommt darum bitte ich sie die afg
spricht von panikmache kritisierte
bewohner maßnahmen als unverhältnismäßig
und attackiert angela merkel persönlich
die bundeskanzlerin hat eben angekündigt
sie wolle in stark betroffenen regionen
brachial durchgreifen
manchmal bricht die ddr erziehung eben
doch durch die anderen
oppositionsparteien konzentrieren sich
auf sachthemen insbesondere für kinder
und bildung tour die regierung zu wenig
weil bildung und forschung mittel nicht
zu verstärken in diesen zeiten dass das
gegenteil der notwendigen sozialen
vorsorge die unser land bundeskanzler
sie haben sofort einen autogipfel nach
wenigen tagen ausgerichtet aber ein
schulgipfel der ist erst monate später
angesetzt worden dass wir jetzt nach
sechs monaten immer noch darüber
diskutieren wann schaffen ihr luftfilter
für die schulen und für die innenräume
dafür singt mein verständnis die spd
verteidigt den haushalt und die
neuverschuldung und lobt sich für ihren
finanzminister ohne die
sozialdemokratische handschrift ohne
olaf scholz wäre vieles davon nicht
möglich olaf scholz ist der richtige
kanzler für deutschland meine damen und
herren eine generaldebatte in der der
wahlkampf langsam aufblitzt genauso wie
eine ungewöhnlich emotionale
la merkel die zahl der kurzarbeiter in
der korona krise geht weiter zurück
und auch die zahl der arbeitslosen ist
gesunken im september waren laut
bundesagentur für arbeit zwei millionen
847 tausend menschen arbeitslos das sind
108 1000 weniger als im vormonat bei
einer quote von 6,2 prozent im vergleich
zum selben zeitraum im letzten jahr
allerdings waren 603 10.000 menschen
mehr ohne job
unser nächstes thema viele prozesse
wurden in fünf jahren diesel skandal
schon geführt aber noch musste sich
keiner der top manager aus dem
vw-konzern verantworten
bis heute der frühere audi chef rupert
stadler steht mit drei anderen in
münchen vor gericht er soll spätestens
im september 2015 von den manipulierten
motoren erfahren haben als der skandal
aufgedeckt wurde danach und das ist der
vorwurf habe er nicht verhindert dass
noch weiter manipulierte audis verkauft
wurden
immerhin mehr als 31.000 stück alexander
pohl berichtet rupert stadler wirkt
zeitweise so als könne er das was ihm
zur last gelegt wird nicht wirklich
nachvollziehen er
der audi zu einem der erfolgreichsten
autohersteller gemacht hat soll
zehntausende kunden betrogen haben
dem ehemaligen vorstandsvorsitzenden
wird vorgeworfen dass er letztlich nicht
eingeschritten ist als es um den verkauf
von dieselfahrzeugen gegangen ist die
deren abgas software manipuliert gewesen
sein soll
mit stadler angeklagt der ehemalige chef
der audi motorenentwicklung wolfgang hat
sowie die ingenieure henning l und
giovanni p letzterer soll ab 2008 die
betrug software mitentwickelt haben ein
bauernopfer sagen seine anwälte
er hat ja nicht im luftleeren raum im
herbst 2015 ist rupert stadler chef von
audi zu dieser zeit muss der
autohersteller einräumen motoren so
manipuliert zu haben dass sie auf dem
prüfstand weniger schadstoffe ausstoßen
als auf der straße statt den verkauf zu
stoppen betriebs stadler laut anklage
weiter die zulassung der manipulierten
autos und ließ für sie werben
stadler weist alle vorwürfe zurück gibt
sich noch 2018 als aufklärer wir kommen
denn noch in der aufarbeitung gut voran
arbeiten unermüdlich an einer
lückenlosen aufklärung über zwei jahre
soll der prozess dauern
im falle einer verurteilung droht rupert
stadler eine mehrjährige haftstrafe
rekordzahlen einer ganz anderen art
kriminalität meldet das
bundeskriminalamt mehr als 100.000
registrierte cyber angriffe im
vergangenen jahr rund 15 prozent mehr
als noch 2008 10 häufig legten die
hacker datennetze lahm um dann lösegeld
für die entschlüsselung zu erpressen
seit einigen monaten machen sich die
täter auch die korona krise zu nutzen
isabel de la vega der schreck beim
high-tech mittelständler schmersal sitzt
tief vor vier monaten mussten hier in
der zentrale des unternehmens in
wuppertal sowie an den weltweit 7
standorten alle maschinen und systeme
komplett heruntergefahren werden
als reaktion auf einen sich rasant
ausbreitenden trojaner
das war ein verschlüsselungs trojaner
das heißt er hätte unsere daten
verschlüsselt so dass wir sie nicht mehr
lesen können unsere sämtlichen systeme
werden unbrauchbar gewesen wir konnten
dem zuvorkommen den wir rechtzeitig den
stecker gezogen haben und haben wir dann
über wochen eben daran gearbeitet unsere
systeme zu einigen haben neu investiert
in neue hardware software und haben im
prinzip unsere ganze infrastruktur neu
aufsetzen müssen kosten der
rettungsaktion über zwölf millionen euro
über 100.000 fälle von cybercrime
registrierte das bka für 2009/10 ein
plus von 15% corona hat nun zusätzlich
für einen schub gesorgt das bka sieht
einen grund in der ausweitung von home
office home office war insofern ein
problem als wir eine vielzahl von an
dürfen feststellen konnten
beispielsweise über fernwartungs systeme
wo versucht worden ist dann die
entsprechenden zugängen zu den
netzwerken zu bekommen corona hat die
digitalisierung vorangetrieben und so
die angriffsfläche für cyber attacken
vergrößert doch es gibt auch ganz eigene
corona betrugsmaschen die korona
soforthilfen zum beispiel
sie sind für unternehmen gedacht und
werden immer wieder auch von kriminellen
beantragt allein in nordrhein westfalen
gab es dazu bislang 1200 strafanzeigen
drei wochen nach der brandkatastrophe im
griechischen lager moria sind die ersten
flüchtlinge von dort in hannover
angekommen
an bord des fluges waren 51 unbegleitete
minderjährige migranten
sie werden jetzt auf mehrere
bundesländer verteilt und müssen noch
ein asylverfahren durchlaufen
mit demselben flug kamen auch 17 kranke
kinder mit ihren engsten
familienmitgliedern der vielleicht
größte frevel den wir unseren planeten
antun sagen wissenschaftler ist das
dramatische artensterben und es sind in
der tat alarmierende zahlen über die
gerade die artenschutzkonferenz der uno
diskutiert eine million tier und
pflanzenarten ist vom aussterben bedroht
mehr als 40 prozent der amphibien und
bei den meeressäugern sind es mehr als
ein drittel
was der mensch tun kann auch im kleinen
zeigt jetzt unser afrika korrespondent
tim kröger am beispiel eines
fischerdorfes in kenia nördlich von
mombasa jeden tag befreien katana gala
und die anderen die selbst gezüchteten
korallen von alben hier an der küste
kenias hat die fischer gemeinde von
kourou wie du ein kleines schutzgebiet
eingerichtet in dem keiner mehr fischen
darf
so sollen sich die bestände erholen die
korallen sollen dabei helfen
wir müssen die korallen aufziehen und
wieder einsetzen weil sie die häuser der
fische sind wenn es hier keine vor ein
mehr gibt dann gibt es auch keine fische
vor 17 jahren begann das projekt und
seither sei ein kleines wunder geschehen
sagen sie hier
die fische kommen zurück unter wasser
vielfalt und farbenpracht sie gras
korallen meeresbewohner frühjahr haben
zu viele fischer dem ökosystem zugesetzt
korallen zerstört nun versuchen sie hier
vor ort den menschlichen eingriff in die
natur zu begrenzen
immerhin auch die bereiche neben dem
schutzgebiet wo gefischt werden darf
profitieren
es gibt jetzt mehr oktopusse wegen des
schutzgebietes sie vermehren sich sehr
und kommen auch in andere gebiete 400
fischer und ihre familien sind an dem
projekt beteiligt langfristig wird
versucht neben der fischerei alternative
einkommensquellen etwa im tourismus zu
schaffen andere fischer gemeinden haben
die idee bereits übernommen
ein bisschen hoffnung in einer
katastrophalen gesamtlage
so jetzt kommen wir zu den sport und das
war's dann ducati ja es gibt ein duo und
das ist doch bekannt die die schalker
wieder in die spur bringen sollen das
ist nämlich manuel baum der wird nach
dem rauswurf von david wagner neuer
cheftrainer in gelsenkirchen
ihm zur seite als assistent steht
publikumsliebling leitung frischer wind
auf schalke nun das wird sich zeigen ein
bisschen humor hat der neue cheftrainer
zumindest mitgebracht es ist eine große
aufgabe
und vielleicht wird sich der ein oder
andere fragen ja ist der baum das ist ja
nicht zu klein für das ganze
aber naldo ist ja auch noch mit dabei
der ehemalige publikumsliebling in
ahldorf hoffentlich ein stück weit die
sonne wieder zurück nach gelsenkirchen
das duo leitet heute bereits das
training am samstag geht es dann nach
leipzig ob dort die negativserie beendet
werden kann ist fraglich
zuletzt beim 1 3 gegen bremen hat sich
eine leblose mannschaft präsentiert der
dringend selbstvertrauen eingeflößt
werden muss das soll vor allem manuel
baum jetzt leisten es gibt leichtere
aufgaben
bibiana steinhaus deutschlands
bekannteste fußball schiedsrichterin
beendet aus privaten gründen ihre
karriere
steinhaus war viermal welt
schiedsrichterin pfiff als erste frau
ein bundesliga spiel der männer heute
abend ihr letzter auftritt im supercup
zwischen den bayern und dem bvb und dass
thomas skulski münchen leider wieder vor
leeren ring ohne zuschauer hier in der
allianz arena weil pandemie level hoch
in münchen und das bedeutet auch für uns
durchgehend mit maske bayern gegen
dortmund die mannschaften sind übrigens
gerade angekommen auch ohne zuschauer
immer ein spiel voller emotionen
hier geht's ums prestige erst recht nach
den niederlagen bei der am vergangenen
wochenende
dabei haben die dortmunder gleich in
mehrfacher hinsicht etwas gut zu machen
die letzten drei spiele in der arena 0
zu 60 zu 50 zu vier glatt verloren
frustrierend möchte man sagen weil man
und das sag nicht ich sondern marco reus
beschissen gespielt habe kann man hier
haben dass er machen
das stimmt thomas vielen dank 20.15
melden sich die kollegen aus münchen
ja jetzt wissen wir alles vielen dank
katja und wir können uns noch die
lottozahlen von heute angucken die
gewinnzahlen lauten 5 720 21 33 43
superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
der oktober startet für manche sonnig
aber es kommt auch regen mehr gleich von
katja honnefer marietta slomka hat das
heute schon alle in der fußball hat seit
pause gegen viertel nach neun und morgen
freut sich an dieser stelle petra
gerster aufsehen
ich sage danke fürs interesse und
wünsche ihnen allen einen angenehmen
abend tschüss
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das kleine
hoch nepomuk wird von zwei seiten in die
zange genommen
zum einen vom osten nämlich mit dem tief
zu rat dass seine wolken unsere richtung
treibt und zum ammann von dem tief
andrea das von westen wolken heran
bringt und da ist auch ein bisschen
regen dabei aber noch nicht in dieser
nacht da wird sich hier unter dem klaren
himmel doch oft nebel bilden
etwas dichter sind die wolken dann schon
im westen und deswegen sinken die
temperaturen dort genauso wie auch in
den küsten von nord- und ostsee auf 13
bis 10 grad sonst wird es wieder mit
einstelligen werten und am kältesten an
der donau mit 3 grad
der erste oktobermorgen bringt uns recht
hohe temperaturen
es sind bis zu 1800 sogar 22 grad
deutlich kühler bleibt es in den
mittelgebirgen vor allen dingen richtung
eifel mit 14 bis 16 grad und morgen
bringen dann die wolken von dem tief zu
etwas regen am längsten gibt es wohl
noch regenschauer an der ostsee
dann gibt es einen freundlichen streifen
hier von nordfriesland bis zum spreewald
im westen sind die wolken dagegen
dichter und bringen auch regen mit und
ganz ähnlich sieht es morgen auch in
süddeutschland aus also strahlender
sonnenschein im osten regen dagegen im
westen und so ähnlich geht es in den
nächsten tagen weiter am dritten oktober
können im osten bis zu 24 grad erreicht
werden schön auch noch